Je rajoute ce petit message avant de commencer la vidéo.
Y'a une bande dessinée qui va sortir sur l'univers de YouTube.
C'est énorme vous allez pas pouvoir la trouver dans le commerce,
et je vous en parle dans une vidéo qui est juste dans cette description.
En non répertorié.
Et il se peut que j'aie un personnage dedans.
Salut, après cette vidéo vous allez être capable de retenir un numéro de téléphone
en entier comme ça à la volée.
Ou n'importe quelle séquence de chiffres,
genre carte bleue, code d'entrée d'un immeuble, ou code wifi.
Le truc vraiment cool c'est que vous allez pouvoir réussir à faire ça,
à la fin de cette vidéo.
Vous suivez cette vidéo, à la fin, BIM,
vous êtes capable de le faire.
Pour ça on va utiliser une version très simplifiée de la table de rappel et du palais mental,
qui sont deux techniques de mémoire,
que vous connaissez si vous suivez la chaîne.
Alors peut être que vous avez jamais pris le temps de faire une table de rappel ou un palais mental
et peut être que vous en avez déjà un.
Peu importe parce que c'est toujours important, voire essentiel
d'avoir plusieurs tables de rappel en fonction de l'utilisation.
Et ce qu'on va mettre en place, là, qui va être très court,
va vous permettre de retenir de manière temporaire mais moyen terme.
Exemple concret: on vous dit un numéro de téléphone, vous avez pas de quoi le noter.
Vous allez le retenir peut-être jusqu'au soir-même, ou jusqu'au lendemain, ou jusqu'au surlendemain,
le temps de le noter quelque part ou de le rentrer quelque part.
Petite nouveauté également sur la chaîne:
Systématiquement maintenant à la fin de chaque vidéo, y aura un écran durant 2 secondes
- donc vous pourrez faire pause si vous avez envie de le lire -
sur lequel vous allez retrouver la date de la prochaine vidéo,
le jour et l'heure où elle va sortir, le prochain live,
les dates et endroits où est-ce que je vais dédicacer le livre,
et toutes les infos que je trouverai pertinentes à mettre.
Et maintenant on attaque la méthode.
Je vous l'ai dit, à la fin de cette vidéo-là, vous serez capable de faire ça.
Donc jouez le jeu en même temps que je vous parle, restez un petit peu focus sur la vidéo,
et pour vous motiver, regardez le temps que fait la vidéo
et dites-vous qu'à la fin, vous serez capable de le faire.
On va commencer par créer une connexion entre les neurones qui représentent les chiffres de 0 à 9,
et des images.
Ça va être une sorte de code secret.
Pour le 0, je vais vous demander d'imaginer un oeuf dans votre esprit.
Vous pouvez fermer les yeux d'ailleurs, à chaque étape, si vous voulez mieux visualiser ça.
Et vous allez le verbaliser à voix haute, ou peut-être en chuchotant suivant le monde qu'y a autour de vous.
0 c'est un oeuf, un oeuf, un 0.
Un oeuf, vous pouvez aussi faire les gestes.
Faites-le, je vous laisse quelques secondes avec mon oeuf...
Ok. Maintenant on va passer au 1.
Le 1, c'est une grande tige comme ça.
Eh bien on va imaginer que le 1 c'est la Tour Eiffel.
Visualisez la Tour Eiffel et essayez d'imaginer que c'est un 1,
et à l'inverse, visualisez un 1 et imaginez que c'est une Tour Eiffel.
Vous allez connecter tout ça ensemble.
Certains ont peut-être envie de me dire: "Oui, mais moi j'suis pas un visuel au niveau de la mémoire"...
Peu importe. En fait, on a tous une très bonne mémoire visuelle.
Chacun à une prédominance ailleurs, mais le visuel fonctionne pour tout le monde.
Le 1, la Tour Eiffel, je vous laisse faire...
Pour le 2 c'est très facile, on va imaginer un cygne.
Parce que le 2, cette courbe-là avec ce trait,
ça rappelle un petit peu un cygne qui serait sur un étang par exemple.
Là aussi, visualisez le 2, le cygne, le cygne, le 2...
Vous pouvez le répéter, vous pouvez le visualiser,
vous pouvez aussi faire des mouvements comme ça.
Vous allez voir, ça prend que quelques secondes à chaque fois.
N'hésitez pas à mettre pause pour 2-3 secondes,
histoire de visualiser sans m'entendre parler en même temps.
Et donc le numéro 2...
Et on va passer au 3.
Et le 3, ça va être une bouche.
Alors je vous explique pourquoi j'ai fait une bouche pour le 3:
parce que ça, ça me rappelle les bouches des dessins
du style Lucky Luke,
où souvent les dessinateurs dessinaient la bouche comme ça
pour mettre un brin d'herbe ou une cigarette dedans.
Oui, je sais, c'est immonde quand je dessine.
Le 3, la bouche... Faites pause si vous avez besoin de 2-3 secondes de plus.
Et on passe au numéro 4.
Le numéro 4, ça va être une planche à voile.
Simplement parce que cette grande aile comme ça peut rappeler la voile d'une planche à voile.
Visualisez le 4, la planche à voile, faites la connexion entre ça.
Vous pouvez le verbaliser, vous pouvez encore faire les gestes pour matérialiser tout ça dans votre esprit.
Et on passe au 5.
Le 5, qui ressemble un petit peu à un S, et qu'on prononce,
ça va rappeler le serpent.
Prenez le temps de visualiser un serpent en forme de S dans votre esprit.
On a presque terminé pour les chiffres.
Le 6, qui sera un sachet de thé.
Parce que j'ai l'impression de voir un fil avec quelque chose au bout
comme un sachet de thé qu'on pourrait tremper dans l'eau chaude.
Vous pouvez même visualiser un 6 que vous êtes en train de tremper dans de l'eau chaude.
Et on attaque le 7 avec la lampe de bureau.
Le 7, on pourrait vraiment imaginer que c'est une lampe de bureau
parce qu'on a cette tige comme ça, qui part du bas,
et ça revient comme ça. On pourrait imaginer un éclairage.
Donc visualisez votre lampe de bureau et voyez le 7 dans cette lampe de bureau.
Plus que 2.
Tiens, d'ailleurs 2, je vous le rappelle, c'est le cygne.
Le 8, à retenir, vous allez voir, c'est extrêmement simple.
Ce double rond, comme ça, vous le faites tomber, et ça nous fait une paire de lunettes.
Donc 8, lunettes, lunettes, 8...
Si vous-même, vous avez des lunettes, vous pouvez même imaginer que c'est un 8 que vous avez sur les yeux.
Et pour finir, le 9.
Le 9, ça va être une pâquerette.
Imaginez que cette barre du 9, c'est une tige qui sort du sol,
et que le cercle comme ça, c'est l'intérieur d'une pâquerette.
C'est juste une pâquerette sur laquelle il manquerait les pétales.
Peut-être ils sont tombés, on n'en sait rien.
En 0, on visualise un oeuf; en 1, c'est une Tour Eiffel;
en 2, vous avez un cygne; en 3, vous avez une bouche;
le 4, c'est donc une planche à voile, vous visualisez l'aile de la planche à voile;
le 5, c'est le S de serpent;
en 6, on voit bien le sachet de thé qu'on trempouille;
en 7, c'est la lampe de bureau;
8, c'est la paire de lunettes; et le 9, avec la pâquerette.
Je vous fais un petit test, et après on attaque la fin de la méthode.
Le test pour consolider ça, c'est que je vous dis un chiffre,
vous essayez de retrouver l'image qui est associée.
Après je fais l'inverse: je vous dis l'image, vous essayez de retrouver le chiffre.
Alors on commence par le 3.
Le 3, quelle est l'image qui est associée?
Voyez bien la forme du 3... Essayez de vous rappeler...
Je compte jusqu'à 2...
...
C'est une bouche.
On inverse. L'oeuf, c'est quel chiffre?
Visualisez l'oeuf, cherchez le chiffre associé. Je compte jusqu'à 2...
...
C'est le 0.
Evidemment, c'est la même forme.
Le 8, à quelle image correspond ce chiffre-là, le 8?
Visualisez le 8 et je vais compter jusqu'à 2. Vous retrouvez l'image...
...
C'est la paire de lunettes, évidemment.
On s'en fait un dernier.
Quel chiffre est associé à une pâquerette? Une pâquerette?...
...
Bon j'allais dire: "qui a plus les pétales" mais c'est un bon indice hein ça quand même.
Je compte jusqu'à 1...
Oui, c'est le 9.
Maintenant je suis persuadé que vous avez bien ces correspondances chiffres/images en tête.
On va créer un mini palais mental, rapidement,
qui vous servira ensuite à cumuler votre table de rappel pour retenir ce que vous voulez.
J'expliquerai ça rapidement à la fin.
Un palais mental, c'est évidemment un lieu; imaginaire ou qui existe,
et dont vous connaissez tous les détails dans votre esprit.
Et c'est un lieu où il y a un circuit, un trajet.
Donc je vais prendre un lieu générique où je suis sûr qu'on va retrouver les mêmes choses et les mêmes objets
et que vous connaissez forcément par coeur.
Dans votre salle de bains, y a forcément un lavabo.
Y a forcément une douche ou une baignoire. Y a forcément une porte pour y rentrer,
y a forcément une lampe quelque part, au plafond ou ailleurs,
et y a forcément un meuble ou un placard, ou une étagère.
Ca va être les 5 endroits qu'on va imaginer.
Et comme je peux pas faire un circuit logique genre en sens horaire ou anti-horaire
puisque chacun à sa salle de bains,
le trajet sera le suivant.
Vous pouvez fermer les yeux si vous voulez, et je vais vous demander d'imaginer, pour commencer, votre douche.
Douche ou baignoire, évidemment.
Ça, c'est l'endroit numéro 1: la douche ou la baignoire.
Ensuite, toujours mentalement, vous allez visualiser la lampe ou le lampadaire, ou le luminaire.
Ça, ce sera l'endroit numéro 2. Donc la douche, et ensuite la lampe.
Visualisez en 3ème position le lavabo.
Y a forcément un lavabo quelque part. Vous le visualisez aussi.
Donc en 1, la douche; en 2, la lampe; en 3, le lavabo.
En 4ème, vous visualisez votre placard ou une étagère si vous avez pas de placard.
Et en 5ème et dernière étape, vous visualisez la porte comme si vous sortiez de la salle de bains.
Alors y a quand même un sens logique à tout ce trajet: c'est un ordre alphabétique.
C'est-à-dire qu'en 1, on a la douche;
en 2, on a la lampe; en 3, le lavabo;
en 4, le placard ou étagère ou meuble;
et en 5, la porte.
On se refait rapidement la table de rappel.
En 0, on avait l'oeuf; en 9, on avait la pâquerette;
en 8, les lunettes; en 7, la lampe de bureau;
en 6, c'est le sachet de thé, hein -c'est pas le plus facile celui-là- ;
en 5, le serpent; en 4, la planche à voile;
en 3, la bouche; en 2, le cygne; et en 1, la Tour Eiffel.
Et on se refait rapidement le palais mental simplifié.
Vous êtes dans votre salle de bains et d'abord vous visualisez la douche,
ensuite la lampe, ensuite le lavabo, ensuite le meuble, le placard, l'étagère
et pour terminer, vous sortez par la porte.
Avant de passer à la dernière étape qui est la plus simple après tout ce qu'on a fait,
c'est juste la réunification des deux,
je vous félicite déjà d'avoir regardé cette vidéo en entier et d'avoir pris
que ces quelques minutes dans votre vie pour maintenant réussir à faire ça tout le temps.
Bravo! Je vous pouce-en-l'airise.
Pour vous faire voir le fonctionnement, on va prendre le cas très concret d'un numéro de téléphone
donc là c'est 10 chiffres mais vous comprendrez assez bien la méthode
pour pouvoir la ré-appliquer à n'importe quelle séquence de 12 chiffres, de 15 chiffres, de 3 chiffres, de 4 chiffres
vous aurez l'outil simplifié, la méthode, vous aurez juste ensuite à l'adapter vous-même, c'est pas très compliqué.
Alors on va imaginer un numéro de téléphone qui n'existe pas.
Le 98 76 54 32 10
En situation, on me dit ce numéro de téléphone,
j'ai rien pour noter, je veux le retenir et je veux être sûr de moi quand je le retiens.
Parce que faire une boucle phonétique ça tient pas longtemps
c'est à dire le répéter en boucle dans sa tête.
Là, on veut être sûr de le retenir à moyen terme,
le temps de l'écrire quelque part.
Donc je vais demander à la personne de me le dire lentement,
nombre par nombre.
Donc en premier, c'est 98.
Nous on sait que c'est 9-8.
et 9-8 c'est quoi?
C'est la marguerite et les lunettes.
9-8
Au premier endroit de mon palais mental simplifié, c'est-à-dire la douche,
je vais imaginer ces 2 objets en action dans un ordre précis.
C'est-à-dire qu'à la place du pommeau de douche,
j'imagine une marguerite géante et du jaune de la marguerite, au lieu que ce soit de l'eau qui tombe,
ce sont des paires de lunettes.
Et je peux déjà passer à la suite parce que c'est tellement incongru,
et on a tellement tout bien fixé dans notre esprit
que dans 2h, 3h, 24h,
on se souviendra en pensant à notre douche de cette marguerite et des lunettes qui tombent.
Donc je peux demander le 2ème nombre, qui est 76.
Donc la lampe de bureau et le sachet de thé,
et je vais mettre dans l'ordre ces 2 images en action au 2ème endroit de mon palais mental.
Je vous rappelle que c'est la lampe (par exemple pour moi c'est mon plafonnier).
Et donc à la place de mon plafonnier, j'imagine ma lampe de bureau, mais à l'envers en fait,
qui est suspendue à l'envers,
et tout autour de l'ampoule je vois des sachets de thé qui sont suspendus.
Un peu comme les mobiles qu'on met au berceau des enfants.
Mais un mobile, là, bien dégueulasse
parce que c'est une lampe de bureau à l'envers avec des sachets de thé qui pendouillent.
Et vous pouvez déjà passer à la suite parce que l'image, elle prend une seconde à faire dans votre esprit
et elle se fixe.
En 3ème, c'est le 54, donc dans votre lavabo,
pour ma part instantanément je penserais que le bec du lavabo, c'est un serpent avec l'eau qui sort,
et qu'il y a un petit voilier dans le lavabo, un mini voilier qui est en train de... ben faire de la voile.
C'est le but d'un voilier, hein!
Je termine rapidement pour aller jusqu'au bout de l'exemple.
Mon 4ème endroit dans mon palais mental simplifié, c'est mon meuble.
Donc je vais imaginer le 32 sur mon meuble.
Le 32, c'est une bouche et un cygne.
Moi mon meuble, c'est plutôt une armoire donc j'imagine une bouche sur le coté que...
dont on ouvrirait les lèvres, plutôt que d'ouvrir les portes,
et à l'intérieur il y aurait un cygne resplendissant, en pleine lumière qui m'attendrait.
Et ensuite je sortirais de ma salle de bain par le 5ème endroit,
c'est-à-dire la porte.
La porte pour moi, ça serait une Tour Eiffel mise à l'échelle de ma porte, évidemment,
donc il y aura des trous, des trucs comme ça,
puis elle sera un petit peu plate, d'ailleurs ma Tour Eiffel.
Mais elle symboliserait le 1, comme elle est plus grande, je sais que c'est le premier,
et l’œuf, je le mettrais en bouton, en poignée.
Avec cette ordre de grandeur un petit peu comme les actions qu'on s'est représentées tout à l'heure.
Je sais que c'est le 1 en premier et le 0 en deuxième,
qui me permet d'ouvrir et de sortir.
Et si, mettons 24h après, j'essaie de me rappeler de tout ça,
j'ai juste à me rappeler de ma douche et instantanément je vois la marguerite avec les lunettes qui tombent;
après je repense à mon ampoule et à la place du plafonnier, je vois cette lampe de bureau avec les sachets de thé comme un mobile;
puis ensuite je pense au lavabo, donc je vois un serpent et puis je vois le voilier dans le lavabo;
et puis ensuite je pense à mon armoire, donc je vois la bouche avec le cygne resplendissant à l'intérieur;
et puis ensuite la porte et je revois la Tour Eiffel avec le bouton, qui est en fait un œuf,
et c'est mon zéro.
Cette vidéo est un petit peu plus longue.
C'est un peu le format que je faisais pour les master class de l'année dernière.
Je pense sincèrement qu'elle peut être utile.
Soit vous avez déjà une table de rappel et ça vous en fait une petite de secours,
c'est-à-dire que quand la première est chargée, vous pouvez utiliser celle-ci de manière temporaire,
et si vous n'aviez ni table de rappel, ni palais mental,
ça vous fait une première étape et un premier outil, comme ça pour retenir des chiffres à l'arrache,
des numéros de téléphone etc..
A la toute fin de la vidéo vous allez retrouver ce nouveau rituel
avec toutes les infos sur un panneau de 2 secondes sur lequel vous pouvez mettre pause pour le lire.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Oubliez pas de la liker, de vous abonner également.
A très bientôt, Tchao !